herzlich willkommen bei bild live wir
wagen eine erste bilanz nach dieser
stürmischen nacht und die wichtigste
meldung haben heutigen morgen ist dass
sie nicht reisen sollten und auch
eigentlich in deutschland nicht mehr
reisen können mit der bahn die bahn hat
quasi komplett in fast ganz deutschland
den fernverkehr eingestellt und wir
schauen auch auf diese frühen
morgenstunden viele menschen machen sich
auf den weg in die arbeit aber auch da
geht vielerorts betroffenen besonders
der norden eine warnung überhaupt aus
dem haus zu den hier sehen wir noch
einmal die mitteilung der deutschen bahn
welche gebiete als betroffen welche
bundesländer betroffen sind wo keine
züge des fernverkehrs mehr verkehren und
sie warnt auch ganz eindeutiges gibt
auswirkungen auch in anderen
bundesländern in niedersachsen müssen
viele kinder zu hause bleiben die
schulen sind dort geschlossener außerdem
auch in nrw und hier sehen wir auch noch
mal die bilder aus wuppertal dort die
schwebebahn betroffener war die
feuerwehr heute nacht im einsatz hat
diesen baum dann bereits zersägt und
jetzt wird gerade derzeit geprüft welche
schäden dieser baum der darf die
schwebebahn gestürzt hinterlassen hat
und das sind bilder aus hamburg die uns
erreicht haben vom fischmarkt dort klar
da weiß man wenn sowas kommt erfährt man
rechtzeitig sein auto weg aber das ist
schon massiv was im moment dort
angekommen ist an wassermassen und das
wird mehr noch in den nächsten stunden
in den nächsten tagen das werden jetzt
ganz viele stürmische und auch orkan
tage es werden weitere höhepunkte morgen
nachmittag morgen abend und dann vor
allen dingen auch am samstag erwartet
also wenn sie nicht unbedingt aus dem
haus gehen müssen lassen sie dass der
ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt hat
das nochmal ganz frisch heute früh zu
seinem appell gemacht er hat uns allen
gesagt ihnen allen gesagt bleiben sie
bitte zu hause heute denn es hat in den
nachtstunden in den morgenstunden schon
ganz viele getroffen mit bäumen auf den
autos über all das werden wir sie rund
um die uhr auf dem laufenden halten ganz
genau dafür sind unsere reporter heute
in ganz deutschland unterwegs von der
küste bis in den süden der hauptstadt
sind wir unterwegs überall auch in einer
wie im westen des landes bestehen auf
dem brocken wir stehen auf den inseln
die teilweise sehr abgeschottet sind
weil die fähre nicht mehr fahren und wir
gehen als erstes nach münster nach
nordrhein westfalen dort wo heute die
schulen geschlossen haben und dort wo
michael engelberg unser kollege die
feuerwehr begleitet sie dort auch schon
einiges zu tun und michael
ja hallo patricia ja gerade stand der
noch in der in der leitstelle der
feuerwehr des kreises steinfurt die sich
in rheine befindet da sind wir gerade
rausgegangen und haben dann ein paar
meter nur zurücklegen können dann sind
wir an dieser tankstelle gekommen da ist
das phänomen baum droht auf tankstelle
zu fallen man sieht dass die
feuerwehrleute und feuerwehrfrauen jetzt
versuchen den baum abzutragen und wenn
man ein bisschen nach da unten guckt auf
den boden was da schon alles abgetragen
wurde da kann man sehen wenn man so was
so ein holzklotz auf die fensterscheibe
auf die windschutzscheibe auf den fuß
auf den nacken oder auf den kopf bekommt
das kann wirklich richtig gefährlich
werden man sieht hier ist ein kran
angerückt die kettensäge roth die ganze
zeit hier wird versucht möglichst
schonungslos den baum abzutragen so dass
wirklich keiner gefährdet ist und
gefährdet wird die tankstelle ist jetzt
auch für den normalen betrieb gesperrt
und hier wird wirklich alles dafür getan
dass solche einsätze möglichst schnell
abgewickelt werden und die gab es
natürlich in nrw ganz viel und auch hier
im kreis steinfurt im gesamten
münsterland es gab an vielen flächen und
vielen stellen gab es stromausfälle in
hörstel riesenbeck in borken auch in der
stadt münster das soll aber in den
nächsten stunden wieder alles gefixt
werden die leute haben das natürlich
über nacht nicht so richtig gemerkt
vielleicht heute morgen wenn wenn die
kaffeemaschine nicht so richtig
funktioniert hat oder der wecker
ausgefallen ist für die kinder gut die
müssen ja in nrw tatsächlich gar nicht
erst in die schule aber hier werdet wird
daran gearbeitet dass man diese ganzen
einsätze möglichst einfache möglichst
zügig abarbeiten möchte nämlich sehr
schnell fertig werden weil man
befürchtet dass es gegen nachmittag
gegen abend weitere einsätze gibt und
der appell nochmal der feuerwehr
möglichst alles festzurren keine
unnützen fahrt machen nicht den helden
spielen in den wald gehen oder den die
gefahr suchen sondern einfach zu hause
bleiben nur das nötigste zu machen und
ja wenn man tanken will muss man jetzt
hier tatsächlich eine andere tankstelle
aufsuchen aber hier ist das alles unter
kontrolle der feuerwehr im garten sieht
man noch das 3 3 4 feuerwehrmänner
stehen die hier auch anweisungen geben
an den mann mit der kettensäge ich denke
das wird jetzt ja noch eine halbe
dreiviertelstunde dauern dann ist das
abgetragen dann wird das alles gesichert
sodass nichts mehr wegfliegen kann und
so dass wir möglichst auch keiner mehr
gefährdet werden kann und dann wird
dieser truppen rücken ganz klassisch
wird zurück zur wache fahren und dann
dort den nächsten einsatz entgegen
nehmen und hoffen dass man mal zeit für
eine tasse kaffee oder ein ordentliches
mitbringt schlanke michael für die erste
eindrücke dort im kreis steinfurt also
die feuerwehr dort im sturm im baum
einsatz aktuell das sind die bilder die
uns aus fast ganz deutschland aktuell
erreichen mich vielleicht noch eine
nachfrage auch bei den männern und
frauen hinter dir direkt im einsatz du
hast das gesagt eine geschichte dieses
orkans dieses sturms ist das der ganz
ganz ausdauernd ist bzw dachte im ersten
kommt der zweite orkan kommt der dritte
orkan das wird uns jetzt über viele
viele stunden über tage begleiten wie
rüsten sich die feuerwehrmänner und
frauen im land im kreis steinfurt hier
speziell für diese ausdauernden einsätze
ja als wir gerade in der leitstelle
waren sind sämtliche freiwilligen
feuerwehren nachalarmiert worden das
heißt die wachen wenig besetzt wurden
wir mussten eine grundbasis anschutz
auffahren das heißt man muss die leute
vorhalten dass wenn es wirklich zum
extremen kommt dass die leute da sind
und auch die berufsfeuerwehr hier
entlastet und was feuerwerk an die sind
gut ausgerüstet die sind vor allen
dingen gut verpflegt die sind gut
versorgt und das
zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl ist in
solchen lagen wie auch alltäglich
unfassbar stark damit die leute nämlich
andere leute retten und damit man denen
helfen kann und hier im kreis steinfurt
hat man sich natürlich lange auf diesen
einsatz vorbereitet und auch der
leitstellen chef hat uns gerade gesagt
im normalen betrieb arbeiten jetzt fünf
leute in der leitstelle wenn es wirklich
richtig brummt sind da auch zehn und
zwölf das sind die leute die die notrufe
entgegennehmen das sind die leute hier
im kreis steinfurt die dann die
feuerwehren den notruf betätigen den
notruf abarbeiten und die einzelnen
feuerwehren zu den einzelnen einsatz
punkten schicken und ich glaube das was
hier in den nächsten drei tagen
geleistet wird das kann man einfach mit
geld auch nicht bezahlen da kann man nur
immer wieder danke sagen danke dass in
diesen job macht danke dass sie auch für
uns da seid und aber der appell der
feuerwehrleute macht kein blöd sind
bleibt schön zu hause das ist das was
ich gerade schon mal gesagt habt keine
helden nummern weil das sind die helden
und die wollen ihre helden fähigkeit für
die einsetzen die wirklich richtig in
gefahr sind und die sich nicht wegen
dummheit in gefahr gebracht haben also
die feuerwehr hatte alle hände voll zu
tun dort in steinfurt und so ergeht es
den einsatzkräften ganz vielerorts im
lande hier nach abstatt beispielsweise
der ausnahmezustand ausgerufen
bis zu 152 km/h können die windböen
stark sein am bad homburger kreuz ist
ein lkw umgefallen auf der a5 also wir
sehen jetzt auch an diesem morgen wo
eigentlich der berufsverkehr ins rollen
kommt gibt es ganz vielerorts probleme
die bahn ist ausgefallen der fernverkehr
in vielen war an vielen strecken 150
einsätze allein in brandenburg zwischen
ein uhr nachts und 3 uhr 50 also die
polizei die einsatzkräfte die feuerwehr
das heer wir haben alle hände voll zu
tun ich habe an die küste wir sehen
nämlich schon klara marie becker weht
ist dort fast schon weg wie ist die
situation dort viele inseln hier der
norden besonders betroffenen sturmflut
in hamburg zu den inseln sind ja
eigentlich abgeschlossen von dem rest
der welt weil die vier betriebe
eingestellt sind beschreibt uns einmal
sankt peter ording unsere kollegin klar
machen becker wie es bei dir die
situation
genau patricia auch hier natürlich in
sankt peter ording und in der umgebung
besteht die gefahr von herabstürzenden
bäumen von gegenständen die umherfliegen
man sieht es auch es ist extrem windig
hier hier wie in einem teilweise die
sturmböen die orkanböen mit bis zu 120
km h um die ohren und die feuerwehr
heute nacht auch schon unterwegs musste
mehrere bäume von den fahrbahnen holen
musste
bestimmte teile in der stadt auch
absichern aber dann gesagt hier den
strand denn sichern sie nicht ab sie
haben aber eine warnung herausgegeben
und haben die menschen auch hier nochmal
jemand bitte geht nicht nach draußen es
ist so stürmisch es ist so windig hier
besteht einfach die gefahr auch einer
sturmflut wir haben gesehen auf dem weg
hierher gerade ist apple das heißt das
wasser läuft zurück aber auf dem weg
hierhin haben wir gesehen dass das
wasser ist schon weit über die dünen
hinaus getreten ist und auch damit
natürlich gesagt jedes mal wenn man auf
eine brücke geht die sand verschiebung
die mit dem wasser also in richtung der
stadt quasi mitgetragen wird der ganze
sand der mitgetragen wird das kann
einfach dazu führen dass eben auch der
der ja der halt auf der brücke nicht gut
ist und auch da könnten menschen dann
natürlich ins wasser stürzen deswegen
wurde ganz klar gesagt bist du bleibt zu
hause und bitte geht nicht an den strand
nicht nach draußen gehen einfach zu
hause bleiben es ist sicherer und ja
soweit mir das hier sehen können machen
die menschen das auch es ist hier wir
sind ja eigentlich fast die einzigen
aktuell
danke klara marie becker nach sankt
peter ording wir gehen weiter zur kehre
ordnerdienst flutgebiet in die region
rund um ahrweiler gefahren ist wir
wollen dort an diesem sturm an diesem
organ morgen hören wie es den menschen
dort geht wie sie diesen extremen sturm
der sich in den nächsten stunden weiter
entwickeln wird über das ganze
wochenende hinweg erleben denn dort
besonders viele bauarbeiten natürlich
überall stehen baufahrzeuge alles ist
noch nicht wieder befestigt man wird
dort in sorge seien im keller schönen
guten morgen dir dass es die region
möglicherweise wieder hart trifft
ja ganz genau keiner sagt es und wir
sehen hier jetzt auch gerade bei mir im
hintergrund auch hier ist die feuerwehr
schon hart im einsatz wir gehen nur
einmal ein paar meter hier die straße
runter denn auch diese straße ist
tatsächlich ja quasi gesperrt dennis
liegen vier große eichen die heute nacht
ja ich umgefallen sind aufgrund des
sturms mitten auf der straße und auch
hier ist dadurch der verkehr
letztendlich ja ins stocken gekommen
weil hier eben kein durchkommen mehr ist
und wir haben gerade mit dem
einsatzleiter dieses dieser feuer welche
gesprochen der nämlich auch von dem blut
von dem von der flutkatastrophe
betroffen war selbst betroffen war und
gesagt hat die leute haben hier wirklich
angst die feuerwehr ist allerdings auch
sehr gut vorbereitet im gegensatz zu der
situation von vor einem jahr aber die
leute haben eben angst die wissen
einfach okay es kann wieder passieren
hier die iaa ist ja direkt um die ecke
jetzt gerade sieht man sie nicht aber es
ist nur wenige wenige hundert meter von
dem fluss entfernt der daneben auch
wieder über überschwemmen könnte
natürlich im moment sind die war
vorwarnungen noch nicht so dass es eben
wieder so schlimm werden sollte aber es
kann eben sein die leute haben immer
noch diese schlimmen bilder von vor
einem jahr im kopf und das soll sich
einfach nicht wiederholen
vielen dank ihrer ortmann für uns dort
vor ort in der nähe von ahrweiler die
menschen haben der naturkatastrophen in
so bitterer erinnerung und blicken jetzt
natürlich auch mit respekt und fürchten
das was da kommen mag in den nächsten
stunden besonders betroffen ist aber
muss man ganz klar sagen besonders der
norden des landes